Violations of,
and then you have people like Milo who was mean to a person and you delete,
you banned him permanently.
There's more than that.
There's a little more to that.
Yeah.
I'm happy to talk about Milo and actually brought the tweets because so,
so let's,
let's preface that by saying,
the point I want to make sure is clear is that you had somebody who actively
called for the death of people.
I understand the context issue.
Maybe he's talking about video games probably takes some skill and scale.
So this is a verified user and the end,
that's just the complexity and enacting not an excuse for why we don't do it in
a particular writer.
But there,
there,
there are a lot of other examples too.
They get into more egregious areas that I've,
I've prepared.
So here we have someone with over 20,000 followers.
He's verified numerous times insights his followers to commit a crime against
these kids.
The action taken against him is delete the tweets.
You get a suspension,
you get time out.
Then you have people like Alex Jones who be rated,
a CNN reporter permanently banned.
You get Milo Yiannopoulos,
he was mean permanently banned.
But that's your impression.
That's not what happened.
Okay,
the details.
Let's do this one at a time.
Let's start with Myeloma.
So what was the details with Milo?
Milo had a number of tweets that violated our rules going back to 2014 but I'm
going to talk about the final three concept.
Um,
he claimed to be a buzzfeed reporter in his bio and he's a verified account.
So that is impersonation.
I'm not sure why he did that.
He did do that.
What?
Buzzfeed's a left wing thing.
So he was doing parody a potentially,
but our parody rules are very specific that if you have an account,
that's me being a is a parody account,
you need to say that it is a parody accounts.
You confuse people.
Everybody who knows Milo would know that he's not a buzz feed reporter,
that people who don't know Milo,
we'll look at that verified account,
write an essay,
but it wasn't verified after a while you removed as verification.
He violated our rules around verification.
So the viable via the verification was removed because of the buzzfeed thing.
I believe so.
I can,
I can confirm that.
I believe so.
He also a docked someone,
he posted,
um,
private information about an individual.
So that was the second one.
He tweeted to somebody else.
Um,
if you were my child,
I'd have dashed your head on a rock and try it again,
which we viewed as a threat.
Really.
That's like he's saying like,
your mom should have swallowed you.
You know,
it's like,
you know what I'm saying?
It's like you're,
you're a mistake.
I'll tell you that's a threat.
I understand why reasonable people would have different impressions of this.
I'm just going through and telling you what they are,
just so we can have all the facts on the table,
right.
And then we can debate them.
And then the last one,
we found a bunch of things that he posted that we viewed as incitement of,
uh,
abuse against Leslie Jones.
So there's a bunch of them.
But the one that I like to look at in which really convinced me is he posted to
doctor tweets that were supposedly by Leslie Jones.
They were fake tweets.
Um,
the first one said,
white people are getting on my nerves.
Like how can you call yourself human?
And then the second one said,
um,
the God damn a slur for a Jewish person at Sony ain't paid me yet.
Damn bics nude better pay up.
And this was just a fake tweet that someone had photo shopped two or two,
two fake tweets and we know they were faked because we could still tell from the
software and they were faked.
You can't always tell is it is possible that he didn't know they were faked.
It's possible to send it to him and he didn't do his due diligence and looking
it up and it is possible.
But it was pointed out to him that they were fake because he left it on.
And not only did he leave it on,
he said,
don't tell me some mischievous intranet.
Rascal made them up.
Exclamation point.
So this and the context of a bunch of other things he was saying towards Leslie
Jones on Twitter,
I and my team felt that this was taken as a whole incitement of harassment
against her.
Wasn't there another issue with multiple accounts that were connected to him?
Uh,
there were a bunch of other issues on the background,
but these are the three primary things that we looked at in terms of the other
things that were in the background.
Weren't they multiple accounts that were connected to him?
Like I think that,
I'm not sure about that.
Uh,
Joe,
I think it was more that we found him to be engaging in coordinated behavior at
inciting people to,
to attack Leslie Jones case like him.
No,
I'm just going to be honest.
When I'm listening to those or listening to read those tweets out,
they don't sound that bad.
And they certainly don't sound as bad as calling for the death of a child who's
wearing a maggot hat.
Throw him into a woodshop or the fact that that guy is still out there tweeting
and Milo's not Milo's initial.
The whole thing stemmed from,
other than the buzzfeed thing,
stemmed from his legitimate criticism of a film.
And he's,
you know,
he's a satirist.
He was mocking this film.
The doxing incident wasn't related.
Doxing.
Why don't we want the [inaudible] stuff?
We all agree that doxing,
if something that Twitter should take action on to percent threaten people in
real life,
and I take an enormous amount of responsibility for that because I fear daily
for the things that are happening on the platform that are translating into the
real world.
So,
uh,
Milo is a contentious figure and there's certainly things you can pull up that I
wouldn't agree with.
Anything he did there.
I think those are horrible.
I think Joe brought some really good points,
but what about Chuck Johnson?
Why was Chuck Johnson Ben?
I don't have those details in front of me.
Time Johnson said that he was preparing something to take out d deray McKesson
and in the Er,
in a journalistic context,
people take this to me and he was going to do a dossier or some kind of hit
piece on Deray is permanently banned.
And my understanding,
and it's been a long time since I've read this,
there was some leaked emails,
I think from Dick Costolo where he said maybe it wasn't deck.
I don't want to drag deck.
I don't know who it was exactly.
They said,
I don't care,
just get rid of him.
And he was off.
So you have,
and again maybe there's some hidden context there,
I don't know.
But on the surface the concern is that this is always leaning towards the left.
Oh it absolutely is.
And I'm,
I'm,
I'm not even getting started.
Yeah,
I can understand why you feel that way.
I don't think that's true.
I think we look at each individual instance of violations of our rules and try
to make the best case that we can and I'm not trying and I do think Joe,
just to just to say I do think we've failed in a couple of ways and I want,
I want to admit that.
Okay.
Number one,
we haven't done enough education about what our roles are because a lot of
people violate our rules and they don't even know it.
Like some of the statistics that we've looked at,
like for a lot of first time users of the platform,
if they violate the rule once,
almost two thirds of them never violate the rules again.
So we're not talking about like a bunch of people accidentally.
Like if they know what the rules are,
most people can avoid it in most people when they feel the sting of a violation,
they go,
okay,
I don't want to lose my rights to post.
Exactly.
And they're,
and they're able to do it.
So we have a lot of work to do on education so people really understand what the
rules are in the first place.
The other thing we have to do to address these allegations that were doing this
from a bias perspective is to be really clear about what types of behavior are
caught by our rules and what types are not,
and to be transparent within the product.
So when a particular tweet is a found to be in violation of our rules being
very,
very clear,
like this weight was found to be in violation of this particular role and that's
all work that we're doing because we think the combination of education and
transparency is really important,
particularly for an open platform like Twitter.
It's,
it's just part of who we are and we have to build it into the product.
I appreciate that.
Your particular thoughts though on those examples that he described when he
talking about someone saying they should throw these children into a wood
chipper versus Chuck Johnson saying he should take this guy,
he wants to prepare a dossier to take this guy out or how do you say it?
I want to,
is that something like I'm going to take out deray Mckesson with he said I'm
preparing to take out Derek,
something like that.
I can't preparing to take him out.
I can understand what it could be misconstrued as he was trying to assassinate
him.
Right.
You could,
you could misconstrue it that but not a direct threat but the other one's a
direct threat.
One guy is banned for life.
The other guy is still still we can,
I'm happy to follow up.
I was,
you don't have all the Chuck Johnson.
It's not about,
one thing is that it's about a pattern and practice of violating her holes and
we,
we don't want to kick someone off for one thing,
but if there's a pattern in practice,
like there was from Milo,
we are going to have to take action at some point because we can't sit back and
let people be abused and harassed and silenced on the platform.